[Music]  we're gonna need a bigger slingshot Fred  we've discovered a third island we need  to put aside our differences and work  together being destroyed actually that  positions been filled  she's super smart who's that and why is  she all over these achievement award I  just don't think this is gonna work okay  so what I'm usually angry walk to  herself  left-handed probably with fun being  alone  [Music]  look that doctor okay guys  step one travel undetected to the island  pull the gadgets you'll see here have  been designed with your current mission  in mind first Bing and visit spray how  long does the invisibility last for  forever why Tina we're not going to be  able to see each other okay so what's  the plan  trust me I know working with what we get  [Music]  [Music]  Nikki's challenging this 12  [Music]  oh it's on Wow - I don't know if I'm  gonna fit in your back anyone smell  bacon  [Music]